the horrific violations of my rights by
crooked Joe Biden's weaponized
Department of Injustice are Unthinkable
it's Unthinkable what's happened so bad
for our country
Democrats all
they lawlessly pierced
my attorney-client privilege with
lawyers what they did to lawyers what
they have done to our lawyers our
lawyers all of our lawyers they've done
things that were absolutely horrible and
unthinkable
the leaking has been unbelievable and
highly illegal they leak
we've learned more about
from The Washington Post New York Times
about the doj's boxes hoax it's a boxes
hoax
than from prosecutors themselves we want
to read about it you pick up the
Washington Post
which is not doing well or you pick up
the New York Times but they'll do better
now because of these things you know
this is the only way they survive but
they'll end up dying
but it's not supposed to be that way we
don't want to learn from the times we
don't want to learn from leaks we want
to learn from the people we're supposed
to learn from it's like a leaking sieve
in Washington but we learned nothing
about the Biden bribery scheme or
special counsel Robert Herr's
investigation Robert Herr is doing the
Biden investigation he's a very
respected very nice person
very nice person
mine's not such a nice person mine's a
deranged lunatic
which are many times the magnitude of
ours in both number and severity
that's the prosecutor that they gave he
has found nothing he totally exonerated
Mike Pence I'm happy about that Mike did
nothing wrong but he happened to have
classified documents in his house
but they exonerated him and Biden is a
different story I mean so much you have
to really think about what I said as a
senator he took all of those documents
it's unprecedented
the prosecutor in the case
I will call it our case is a thug I've
named him deranged Jack Smith
I wonder what his name used to be Jack
Smith it sounds so innocent doesn't it
Jack Smith what's his name Jack Smith
he's a very nice man
he's a behind the scenes guy
but his record is absolutely atrocious
he does political hit jobs he's
been known to viciously arrest a certain
Governor you know the governor Bob
McDonnell of Virginia and absolutely
ruined his life and the life of his
family all these wonderful family
members I knew them
only to have the case overturned eight
to nothing by the Supreme Court he
destroyed that man and he destroyed that
family
and by the way
I will tell you I'm here and I love you
all
and we can take it
but what these thugs what these thugs
have done to my family is a disgrace I
will tell you that I say it to all of
the fake news because there's a lot of
it backwards
what they did to my family and that
young man right there
he's answered more subpoenas than any
human being in the history of the world
and you know what they have nothing
after all of those subpoenas literally
thousands of them
Congress
fake councils Mueller report all of this
all he did is answer subpoenas all the
time at least he's become very
experienced at that congratulations
But Eric is fantastic and what he and
Don Ivanka and the whole group that's
what they've gone through and these are
serious people
these are serious people but what he's
done to my family what they have done to
my family is horrible he also tried to
Railroad John Edwards on a completely
bogus legal theory that didn't hold up
in court
it's no wonder this raging lunatic was
shipped off to the Hague to prosecute
war criminals using globalist tribunals
not beholden to the Constitution or the
rule of law two things Jack Smith
clearly disdains you take a look at this
guy he looks like a thug
but then I watched him make a speech the
other day and he was trembling because
it wasn't his territory he feels much
safer in the inner sanctums of the
Department of Injustice where he can be
in his room and scream at people
he's a raging and uncontrolled Trump
hater
as is his wife who also
happened to be the producer of that
Michelle Obama puff pieces total puff
piece
this is the guy I've got
don't forget this persecution is being
done by the same weaponized agencies
that for seven years have been running
illegal psychological warfare campaigns
against the American people much as if
they were trying to destabilize a
foreign country from the russia-russia
Russia hopes to the no collusion Mueller
Witch Hunt
to impeachment hoax number one
impeachment hoax number two the 51 lying
intelligence offers how about them
they said it's Russia disinformation and
they knew it wasn't
the fake dossier
paid for by the Democrats how about the
fake dossier remember that one you think
that was easy to go home and say Hello
darling how are you when they read about
that
wasn't easy at all
spying on my campaign we caught them
spying on my campaign the FBI Twitter
files and so much more
it's all been a battle of disinformation
one thing after the other
and all to protect the radical left
Misfits
it's also no coincidence that these
charges against me came down the very
same day
evidence revealed Joe Biden took a five
million dollar bribe from Ukraine took a
five million dollar abroad
but the FBI and the justice department
don't even want to talk about it
they showed something on television
tonight it had zero time on the three
major networks zero but my impeachment
had almost all the time I think I had
351 minutes they had no minutes
okay
I think a lot of people are going to
vote yeah I think a lot of people
[Music]
I will tell you I just left Miami and
I've never seen love in the streets like
that I've never seen it we've seen a lot
of love
I've never seen love like that because
they know they know what we all go
through they know what we've gone
through and they see it and they're
smart and you know many of those people
coming from Cuba Venezuela other
countries they've seen this happening to
their countries I used to say that
the United States if it keeps going this
way it's going to be Venezuela on
steroids and now we're buying oil from
Venezuela can you believe we have more
Liquid Gold under our feet than any
other Nation but we're buying tar
from Venezuela and we're refining it in
Houston the dirtiest worst oil probably
anywhere in the world
and we're refining it so you can imagine
what's going up in the air and all
beautiful stuff we're not taken out of
the ground and making a lot of money and
paying off debt and reducing taxes still
further which we were in the process of
doing
they want to distract from the real
Espionage and the real crime so let's
use president Trump to do so let's go
out and let's indict president Trump so
they don't talk about the five million
dollar bribe just yesterday Senator
Grassley revealed that the barisma
executive who allegedly paid the bribe
reportedly has crooked Joe
on tape they have 17 tapes I understand
that he must be a nice guy to deal with
right
the guy from barisma nice company
they got him and Hunter on 17 different
types supposedly but the FBI isn't
showing them
remember they impeached me for asking a
simple question about Biden's corrupt
dealings in Ukraine and now they see
that once again I was right I was right
I was totally right
Joe Biden and the radical left can take
foreign bribes
and be totally protected Republicans all
you must finally get tough you've got to
get tough you've got to get tough and
you got to show them
when you arrest your leading political
opponent we no longer have a democracy
when people are allowed to pour through
our open borders and our elections are
rigged our country is in very serious
trouble
when inflation is allowed to rage when
energy Independence and dominance it's
we had Independence and dominance we
were going to be soon very very dominant
within six months we're going to
dominate the whole world with energy
make a fortune we were going to be
paying off debt and lowering taxes at a
level that nobody's ever seen and they
came in and they ended it
but when that's taken away from us when
interest rates and taxes spiral upward
in an uncontrolled way
when murders are allowed to roam
murderers these are horrible Killers
murderers are allowed to roam the
streets of our democrat-run cities
unchecked
but the incompetent district attorney in
New York indicts Trump for a crime that
everybody agrees every pundit everybody
there is no crime
but murderers go out and nobody ever
even comes and knocks on their door and
they know they're there and they know
their rooms and they know their
locations and they're roaming our cities
all over and some of them are coming in
right now through our borders
but then you have a nation that as we
are is in serious serious decline we
have a nation in Syria state line
if the Communists get away with this
it won't stop with me
they will not hesitate to ramp up their
persecution of Christians pro-life
activists parents attending school board
meetings and even future Republican
candidates which they do
we must end it permanently and we must
end it immediately now that the seal
[Applause]
so important is broken the seal is
broken by what they've done they should
never have done this
this was an Unwritten rule you just
don't
unless it's really bad but you just
don't but the seal is now broken
in addition to closing the border and
removing all of the criminal elements
that have illegally invaded our country
make it America energy independent and
even dominant again and immediately
ending the war between Russia and
Ukraine I'll have it ended in 24 hours
I will appoint a real special prosecutor
to go after the most corrupt president
of the history of the United States of
America Joe Biden
and the entire Biden crime family
name a special prosecutor
and all others involved with the
destruction of our elections our borders
and our country itself they're
destroying our country
and when I'm re-elected and we will get
reelected we have no choice we're not
going to have a country anymore I will
totally obliterate the Deep State we
will obliterate
the Deep Stone
and we know who they are I know exactly
who they are
they want to take away my freedom
because I will never let them take away
your freedom it's very simple
they want to silence me because I will
never let them silence you they want you
silent
and I am the only one that can save this
nation because you know they're not
coming after me they're coming after you
and I just happen to be standing in
their way and I will never be moving
on November
November of 2024 Justice will be done we
will take back our country and we will
make America great again thank you God
bless you all thank you thank you very
much great job thank you
[Music]